grande nouvelle aujourd'hui
regardez ce que j'ai là dedans sa voix
si ça vous parle
alors si vous avez cliqué si vous savez
ce qu'on reparle aujourd'hui il ya ici
le web plus cette paix qui arrive et
pour tout vous dire aujourd'hui au
moment où on tourne on né le 20
septembre au 20 septembre
alors il faut toujours un petit pas en
avant de publier parce qu est ce qu on
appelle un embargo
ce qui veut dire que j'ai absolument pas
le droit de vous parler de ce produit
avant la date de lever l'embargo en
empêche le puissant tout cas le tour
n'est donc là dedans on ap le web + 7
qui est là l'idée aujourd'hui c'est de
n'ouvrir de faire le roxy sortir le test
un peu plus tard chaque chose en son
temps
les rouges ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on ne
leur ensemble et je vous laisse me dire
ce que vous en pensez en main en
commentaire
[Musique]
voilà la boîte alors c'est un peu énorme
c'est de bien le mettre dans le cas le
truc est vraiment énorme
alors attendez comment ça c'est par
dessus que je dois donc pouvoir
l'enlever comme ça voilà on se retrouve
bien évidemment avec la jolie boîte
never sitl retrouver le logo alors c'est
vrai que ça c'est super c'est un package
spécial pour les médias vous si vous
achetez des smartphones vous aurez pas
s'abaisser permettre de le montrer tous
les accessoires normalement au
classement à cannes on s'amuse vraiment
que la géométrie lâché one plus c'est
pas mal ça parce que je vais me marrer
toute la journée leur ferme à auvers
fermés ou vert bronze j'arrête oklahoma
rythme notre notre niveau de lecture
juste besoin de plus ici nous ont juste
mis la marque rien donne donc en fait ce
qui est très drôle c'est voyez quand ils
conçoivent un objet comme ça et
réfléchissent toujours comment ça va
être ouvert dans quel ordre ça c'est
assez marrant dont vous avez votre logo
universitaire vous ouvrez en plus par
one plus différents niveaux d'ouverture
lecture vous avez si la petite languette
on tire sur la petite languette à ne
décolle qu'est-ce qu'on adapte donc je
suppose que je veux voir
waouh regardez ici le one + seventy on
ne puisse septs et donc là on ouvre
davantage vachement cool le média guil
il est vraiment superbe
ça vous explique tout en fait toutes les
infos sont plus sceptiques en teintes
fluide amoled leur écran tout tout tout
tout seul mode 90 hertz fui la molette
vont ils tout cas super chouette j'adore
c'est vraiment très bien travaillé d'un
point de vue marketing c'est vraiment
une expérience est superbe et le boulot
en tout cas à chaque fois qui est fait
au niveau des packagings pardonne plus
c'est hyper hyper hyper impressionnant
si vous regardez les packagings on a ici
là on regarde et on va comparer un peu
jazzy beaucoup à chaque fois hop là le
boulot qui est fait pas loin de plus et
plus ça va plus c'est énorme ça s'est un
peu plus sommaire par rapport à ce qu'on
avait là bas l'expérience est déjà
vraiment hyper cool on devrait rester
pour le système ça voyez on ouvre comme
cette attaque comme un petit gâteau
unlock de speed la langue est là vous
aviez ça comme ça ici vous retrouviez
ensuite votre smartphone
c'est la boîte du e7 pro go beyond the
speed world boxing si vous vous en
souvenez pas alors pareil on nous voyait
neller sitter
on enlevait sa tactique le petit média
qui vous avez votre smartphone à
l'intérieur mais c'est vrai que là avec
nouveau packaging
ils ont fiché le lit veulent en tant qu
on continue donc ici qui on a donc
effectivement ça ça c'est pour venir
nettoyer le smartphone tout votre bien
ensuite
ah oui vachement cool c'est à chaque
fois en plus vous avez un vrai travail
sur les géométrique est fait là dedans
voyez que ses contours dessinée avec le
rectangle le rectangle un petit peu
moins prononcée est ce que tintin
biseautés on retrouve en plus les
petites bandes noires son côté il ya
vraiment un très très beau travail on
continue dans le domaine de la langue
est où on l'a très clairement c'est le
smartphone c'est marrant qui s'amenait
en sens ce que ces cépages aurait plus
ni comme ça je sais pas c'est bizarre
dans ma vie c'est comme ça parce que là
vous avez le message bref ça c'est
chouette never site qu'est ce qu'on a
ici attendait ce jour toujours curieux
aa [ __ ] c'est une trappe le glow ça
c'est parce que j'adore et onext
horrible begins crir avec mon bel accent
away huawei vachement cool ce carnet
j'adore trop cool ok incarna idées pour
bosser ça c'est parfait pour moi
ensuite on trouve la trappe qu'est ce
qu'on est sûr mais de la coque waouh
alors déjà ne serait-ce qu'en regardant
les coqs si vous regardez bien ça vous
donne une idée du smartphone vous voyez
effectivement le module photo quiron ici
on a le rouge le carbone et le gris un
peu plus standard moi ça me redonne plus
sept projets ça et peut-être que le
carbone sera intéressant à voir ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on a alors ça situe ici ça
ça s'enlève à on se retrouve ici avec
les boulettes wireless deux pôles comme
appétit tout ça c'est vachement cool je
crois que là on a fait le tour de la
boîte une fois de plus le boulot qui est
fait là dessus juste dingue maintenant
on va s'ouvrir ce truc
on va regarder à quoi ressemble ce
smartphone on veut faire un tour du côté
des specs mais ouais voilà moi je suis
hyper en balises je peux pas leur dire
des millions de fois mais c'est vrai que
vous savez l'expérience du déballage est
hyper importante alors une fois de plus
la boîte cas là c'est pas une botte que
vous allez avoir vous c'est un coffret
je pense médias à moi qui sont
commercialisés je suis même pas sûr ça
en tout cas c'est ce que vous pouvez
avoir
c'est au niveau design ça déchire
l'heure est venue d'ouvrir cette jolie
boîte alors à temps et par où ça
commence dans l'open comment open comme
ça je prends
les feuillages on commence à un truc
cool ça c'est vachement bien
alors c'est une visite très c'est beau
c'est pratique
vient alors quoi lapin alors c'est
toujours en exercice
voilà on va regarder même niveau je
pense nos niveaux de lecture écriture ou
être plus je vais venir tirer comme
simple le slogan ici nevers sitl
disposition ils voient bien plus
sûrement c'est un peu compliqué parce
qu'ici à l'intérieur laissez-moi jeter
un petit coup d'oeil
parce que ça pour le coup c'est ce que
vous avez dans votre smartphone alors ça
c'est cool invitational et or ça ça
marche toujours il m'est toujours leur
petit courrier vous avez le courrier du
boss qu'est-ce qui nous a écrit pitt bon
bah écoutez si je vous laisserai le lire
je me suis arrêté tension fait la poste
top pouvait lire voilà c'est une bonne
lecture j'espère que ça aurait été les
petits autocollants voyais plus never
see quel tout ça tout va bien les
garanties les informations ensuite on
passe à la partie la plus intéressante
le smartphone on regarde ça donc
quelques secondes ça s'est un peu caché
ça ça c'est un truc à peut-être un peu
améliorée parce que on le voit pas trop
tout est tellement bien parfait que je
me dis tiens il doit y avoir une petite
languette
effectivement elle est née à les cacher
mais je vous assure que c'est la
personne de lavéra salut toi petite
coque transparente que mignonne de
couvrir votre tiroir de cartes si votre
blog de charge votre câble ouais cool
j'adore quand c'est tout neuf comme ça
que ça brille c'est beau alors vous a
dit effectivement qu'il était plus clair
que le one + 7 pro et on a donné la
raison
je la trouve un peu dingue la raison
c'est que en fait beaucoup de personnes
disaient que tout vienne +7 procès
couleur est belle mais dès qu'il ya
moins de lumière des moyens peu dans le
noir eh bien on le voit pas ce qu il est
noir donc du coup ils ont offert tout
cas peu plus clair bon après ça marche
c'est sympa ça franchement c'est très
très très très joli on passe
effectivement d'un design avec les
caméras comme ça un design euros et même
si je vous montre le one + 6 t de
l'année dernière voyait l'évolution one
+ system one + 7 projets pas loin de +7
ici mais là on n'arrive carrément dans
tout autre chose on arrive dans leur ont
alors le rond c'est la mode un peu cette
fin d'année aux annonces un design plus
fin plus léger facile à prendre a une
main je suis d'accord pour l'utiliser à
une main comme ça c'est cool par contre
pour poussera les chercheurs ont quand
même utiliser demain sinon c'est
rapidement galère par contre la prison
est bien je vous conseille quand même de
le protéger
c'est par contre ces smartphones de les
protéger si vous voulez pas aller voir
s'abîmer s'éclater sas quand même hyper
hyper important alors on va retrouver
les grands classiques sur une plus le
bouton pour l'allumer pour étendre et si
le bouton pour choisir si vous
les la sonnerie juste le vibreur ou
alors carrément le silencieux pour être
tranquille un haut parleur qui se situe
là votre tiroir de cartes sim qui permet
de la double sim votre prise en main le
micro qui est caché juste la voyez c'est
pas mal ces 10 cas c'est sympa vous
retrouver ici votre bouton de volume
ici le micro pour la réduction de bruit
à savoir vous avez un corning gorilla
glass à l'arrière comme à l'avant j'ai
pas le numéro 6 à 1,5 ou je sais pas
c'est absolument aucune information
là-dessus la grosse nouveauté c'est cet
appareil photo circulaire existant en
deux couleurs ici j'ai le glas cible
c'est le bleu clair mat plutôt sympa il
existe aussi dans une couleur qui
s'appelle frosties silver qui est un
gris métallique toujours matt
moi j'aime bien je trouve que one piece
une fois de plus ça a bien bossé sur ce
modèle alors on regarde juste pour
l'instant le point de vue extérieur
jalbert est sûre le moment un peu un pur
religieux autant valley mais son
smartphone comme sa prise en main global
est quand même vachement cool hein alors
il ya plein de puteaux pour expliquer
comment ça marche moi j'aime beaucoup en
tout cas voilà plutôt qu'il ya un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
déverrouille rapidement ça c'est cool ça
marche mais j'aime bien les animations
quand ça déroule comme ça et ça j'adore
ce qu il ya très très très très très
chouette bloqué fait de la suite par une
puce alors après bon le truc que
j'aimerais un petit peu moins sur cette
fin d'année c'est cette approche même si
elle est réduite donc ça c'est vrai
qu'il ya un truc qui est assez
intéressant nous annonce une encoche qui
réduit de 31 % qui est plus petit que le
28 sept
quand je sais pas si vous vous rendrez
compte comme ça que j'ai plus de
batterie dans one + 6 t et je n'ai pas
charger leur coach est quand même
vachement plus de titres ça c'est
vraiment non négligeable à l'avant vous
avez donc toujours un écran amoled ce
qu'ils appellent le fluide display 6,55
pouces de diagonale on a un ratio qui
change cette fois ci on d'un ratio vingt
neuvième
on se retrouve avec un truc qui est un
peu plus long on n'est pas sûr du 19 9e
pourquoi pas mais il faut savoir que
vous avez le format cinéma qui est
cinémascope ainsi beaucoup de
smartphones aujourd'hui c'est le 21 9ème
ce format là il pas mal par contre ce
qui va être compliqué pour moi je fais
notamment et pas mal de mes petits
confrères sur youtube c'est que bon moi
je suis en 16/9 donc là il va falloir
vraiment décrocher y en a plein qui sont
18 9e alors leur 29e j'imagine même pas
l'histoire parce que le problème c'est
que si vous le regardez après sur un
écran ordinateur vous avez une vidéo qui
est juste une bande et ça devient
rapidement pas terrible alors bon face à
ses dettes ou qu'il va falloir voir
aussi par contre on a toujours le taux
de rafraîchissement de 1090 r compatible
hd r10 plus on a un retour haptique il
ya un gros travail qui a été fait sur la
réduction de lumière bleue 40% de
adduction de lumière bleue donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment cool séduit
fhd plus de 1400 par 1080 pixels
on a un écran qui est plus clair 27%
plus clair en plein soleil qui peut
aller jusqu'à 1000 ni sac c'est plutôt
cool
on a aussi pas mal de choses un mot
lecture qui optimise et optimisation de
la saturation des contrats soit voilà un
truc est vraiment plus optimisée sur le
tapis donc on au repas grâce à vous le
dire lors des phases de test donc je
vous invite à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas en plus ce truc qui est
vachement cool c'est que vous avez un
sage aimait déjà sur le banc ne plus
être haussé les haut parleurs stéréo
haut parleurs ici un grand haut parleurs
là qui est tout le long je ne sais pas
si vous vous en rendez compte qui est
juste énormissime
et le truc qui vachement cool avec ça
c'est qu'en fait vous invention qui est
plus immersif leurs avoirs je vous le
dirai si le son est aussi bon que sur le
one + 7 pro en plus de ça vous avez une
compatibilité dolby est mon truc
vraiment cool ici par contre pas deux
prises jack donc si vous voulez écouter
c soit qu'un casque bluetooth soit avec
un casque ici en usb c'est bon en terme
de puissance on a un snapdragon 855 plus
c'est ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui beaucoup de performances 8
gigas de ram
lp ddr4 x pour être très précis 128 giga
de stockage en urss 3.0 ayant une
version 256 giga qui a priori existe
rennais qui seraient pas disponibles sur
le marché français dont celle là on
l'oubli on la met de côté on a
uniquement de 8 plus 128 non extensible
une batterie de trois mille huit cent
millions père heures mais là où ça
devient encore plus dingue c'est la
charge rapide vous avez la marque
je dis pas si toutefois la mrap charge
ces palabres ah ben c'est pas grave tu
te rates ça se mange à celle de la varde
charge 30 thé qui serait 23 % plus
rapide faut être très précis 23 % plus
rapide que la varappe charge 30 et qui
vous permettrait de recharger votre
smartphone de 1 à 70 % en seulement 30
minutes et jusqu'à 100% en 60 minutes
autant dire que ça va déjà hyper huit
mois jacques moins de +7 et pro ça
carbure je sais que je déçois j'oublie
le charge le soir je le mets paf temps
de prendre une douche et la bim
c'est quasiment chargé c'est vraiment
cool bon par contre si vous êtes adepte
de la recharge sans fil ici il n'a
toujours pas pour l'instant chez one
plus pas de recharge sans fil on verra
la vie il tourne sur oxygen os 10
android dit sur une optimisation des
jeunes vont déjà moi ça j'aime bien
aussi jeannoise tout ça ça marche bien
pour l'utiliser au quotidien je veux que
c'est plutôt cool est un des points
forts sur une plus c'est aussi la partie
photo qui marche plutôt bien
vous avez aussi une caméra de celle
fille de 16 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
c'est une caméra sony et vous avez à
l'arrière un trip module photo alors
vous avez des trucs intéressants
vous avez déjà un capteur principal de
48 mégapixels c'est la somme l'élite 586
qu'un équivalent 26 mm ouvre à f 1.6 et
une stabilisation optique dessus vous
avez un téléobjectif vont être faire un
zoom x 2 de 12 mégapixels un équivalent
de 51 mm ouvre à f 2.2 et vous avez un
ultra grand-angle 16 mégapixels qui
balancent 17 mm qui a un grand temps que
217 degré qui ouvre à f 2.2 et qui vous
permettra en plus de faire de la macro
jusqu'à 2,5 cm le truc intéressant fait
pas ce qu'il faut savoir que il ya un
petit moteur de sulky à faire bouger
votre gentil qui permettra de faire soit
de la macro soit du très grand tambour
ça vous le voyez pas il ya une petite
innovation intérieur donc ça c'est
franchement cool et vous pouvez fumer
juste en 4k à 30 ou à 60 images par
seconde alors en 1080p à 30 60 images
par seconde pour faire du snow motion et
pas mal de choses et justement il ya
plein de trucs intéressants au niveau
software parce que ce qui est vachement
couleurs moi je le découvre c'est
vraiment la première prise en hommage à
l'ouvrir avec vous en direct peut faire
la vidéo que l'ultra grand temps de
choses qu'on ne pouvait pas faire avant
donc ça c'est quand même plutôt cool
voyez là je me mets comme ça attaque hop
ça c'est ce qui est normal le zoom x 2
et là je suis sur l'ultra grand dole
donc ça c'est plutôt bien je peux aussi
utiliser l'ultra grand-angle pour le
mode nuit j'attendais où est ce qu'ils
les paysages nocturnes donc la normale
en jade et que çà et là je peut switcher
sur l' ultra grand-angle donc je sais
pas si ça va bien marcher ou pas ou
c'est rigolo vendu que ça fait avoir on
voit peu le traitement s'assied main on
verra lors de l'heure des phases de test
je vous dirai tout ça a priori aussi une
optimisation au niveau des contre jours
les modes portrait aussi vous pouvez
utiliser soit comme ça soit carrément à
une plus grande distance donc vous avez
deux distances voyez pourquoi ça c'est
rigolo pu passer le sujet entre les
boules marque la 0 5 et de m là vous
placez le sujet entre 30 cm et de m donc
ça c'est plutôt cool aucun n'a pas une
petite innovation un logiciel vous
pouvez aller plus loin du haut niveau du
contre jour des contours ils sont plus
destinés qu'à plus de profondeur la
vidéo ci est mieux stabilise
et sur les modes vous avez aussi une
évolution ça c'est une mise à jour
logicielle qui était fait y'a pas
longtemps sur zenden vous savez les
modes sais je pose mon téléphone et je
vais pas commenter pendant tant de temps
donc tout est désactivé sauf les appels
d'urgence vous choisissez le temps vous
voulez vous voulez être tranquille
pendant 20 minutes 30 minutes 40 minutes
voire carrément une heure où personne ne
peut vous joindre vous pouvez pas vous
connecter sur les réseaux sociaux
l'idée par exemple c'est juste pour vous
le posez sur le chevet vous maîtrisez le
mode comme ça vous savez que vous
n'allez pas passer votre temps à
regarder un style à moi comment et des
chaussures ou ce que vous voulez donc là
vous êtes quand même relativement
tranquille je vous le disais il a donc
une double simila du bluetooth 5.0 il a
également du ls je vous parle pas pour
l'instant ni du tarif ni de la date de
sortie sens ne reparlera dans quelques
temps pour l'instant il a juste été
présenté en un si vous voulez tout
savoir je t'invite à vous abonner parce
que je vous emmène avec moi lors de la
présentation d'ici quelques jours je
vous dirai tout sur le prix sans date de
sortie sur plein d'autres choses aura
probablement des surprises donc on en
reparle très très très prochainement a
vous de me dire comment vous le trouvez
comment vous trouvez ce one + 7 et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de nous
écouter un peu circulaire c'est un truc
qui vous plaît qui vous parle cette
couleur comment vous la trouvez toutes
ces petites innovations mais boutonne
toutes ces petites nouveautés
même du côté logiciel j'ai hâte de voir
vos commentaires alors ce que vous en
pensez en bas si c'est un smartphone qui
vous intéressent vous donnant par là
très très très très très prochainement
je vous dirai tout sur les prix tout ça
tout ça tout ça pour ça on leur parle un
peu plus tard d'ici là je vous souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur soit il sage il vous
envoie ce à plus tard ciao